yeah anyway so that's me
yes we can start or can we have you like
the ones who want to follow along you've
gotten the installation mostly done very
good okay so that's that part zero the
data prerequisites so this first part is
just going to be sort of a very quick
general introduction to neural networks
and there's the desert there's a data
set that we'll be using it is in German
on purpose because I want you to get
yourself into the mindset of like of
thinking about natural language and
applying these methodologies to
languages other than English because
there's various different sort of
problems that arise when you're dealing
with languages other than English and
it's useful to have those in mind I have
some examples of goals
later on there's a ton of links I've
tried to make sure that they're all to
open access journals so you don't need
to log into anything or be an
institutional subscriber or anything you
should be able to just access all of the
research papers that I link link to in
the presentation so prerequisites neural
networks have in general
[Applause]
let me just start a timer for myself
there we go
for parts there's that there's the
network architecture whether you're
using a feed-forward neural network or a
recurrent neural network or the
transformer or convolutions or whatever
how deep tane layers or how deep the
network is the layer size is how they're
connected all of that that's your that
you touch that's the network
architecture but there's a bunch of
other things that are also important
there's the optimizer the algorithm that
you use when data is passed through the
network and you have some loss function
the optimizer then given the loss
function and the gradients the optimizer
will actually do updates to your network
parameters and it is not it's it's not
it's not an insignificant part of how
the network learns is the the network
architecture itself is just a static
thing the thing that actually makes the
Train network have some utility is the
fact that the optimizer has done all of
these adjustments and there's a whole
bunch of different kinds of ways of
doing that there's a quick overview of
how that works then there's a learning
rate scheduler which in the NLP
community has become relatively
significant as well recently so the idea
is that you don't just use a single
fixed learning rate throughout the
entire training but you have a schedule
that changes what the learning rate is
depending on where you are on the on the
learning cycle
this is especially important for as the
networks get consoled the intuition kind
of behind this is that as the network's
get deeper and deeper you want to have a
some kind of a schedule to that so that
right up the beginning when the network
hasn't seen a lot of data and hasn't
learned a lot of things yet you have a
very very small learning rate so you're
doing small kind of incremental
adjustments until you get to a somewhat
more stable state and the network has
been able to ideally sort of propagate
some kind of wisdom through well the
network and then you can start sort of
making a slightly more larger adjustment
hopefully you won't need to anymore but
that's the idea and then of course
there's the learning objective or the
loss function which is completely
problem dependent can be a document
classification problem as is the case
for this tutorial can be some language
models some unsupervised being dist
various different kinds of language
models as well can also be some other
token level classification tasks like I
don't know named entity recognition for
instance and these loss functions depend
a little bit on exactly what problem it
is that you're you're trying to solve
the PI torch documentation itself
contains quite a lot of reasonably good
tutorials with downloadable notebooks on
NLP as well so I recommend that you go
and look at those afterwards ok network
architecture is it
it's the font size ok vitals can you the
people in the back corner there you can
see what's on the board
Darwyn protests okay so this is a simple
feed-forward neural network and this is
in pi torch so what happens is there's a
definition of what the network is this
is not how it needs to be implemented
this is just a decision that I have made
on how to implement it so there's a
layer spec which you will see later what
that contains and then there's a list of
modules each of that each module in that
list of modules is just a linear layer
with some number of features coming in
and some number of features going out
and these the numbers of features coming
in and going out are both contained in
this layer spec that is passed into the
class ideally you would also initialize
the weight but I've left that out for
the time being and then there's an
activation function that is applied to
each one of the layers there's a forward
pass this is this is kind of a specific
thing for pi torch you write your
forward pass as yourself I finally
useful because it kind of it both allows
you to think but it also forces you to
think on how exactly does the data pass
through the various different layers in
there so what comes in is some instance
X first we have no output then we start
going through all the layers that we
defined earlier we pass in the first
instance just the X through the layer
and then the output of the layer through
the activation function store that again
in the output and then on neck on the
further iterations we pass the output of
the previous layer into the next layer
and sort of keep doing the same thing
and you can add profile you can add blah
blah blah that this is just the simple
feed-forward neural network and then
last we apply a locks of maxed it just
turns whatever the network predictions
are into some kind of probabilities and
return that so then we have two classes
some number of features and then this is
on layers back so we have n features 50
coming in so our bottom layer is gonna
be 50 features it consumes vectors that
have 50 elements and it outputs vectors
that have 25 minutes and then the next
layer takes the output of that and then
outputs a vector that has one entry for
each of the classes that range and now I
should be able to run that all right so
we create our feed-forward Network we
have some random data that we feed
through that is completely arbitrary
what we're doing here but you can see
what happens so we have inputs which are
just random numbers ten examples of 50
features each and get probabilities back
or something that looks like but as you
can see the probably if you take sums
over these rows you can see that
everything sort of sums to 1 because the
network hasn't actually learned anything
all the weights are wrapped all the data
is random so you get back just a uniform
distribution over the classes and this
we can change this arbitrarily we can
set that to a hundred features or add
new layers here whatever all right is
that sort of roughly okay this is it's
the
reason I'm sort of laboring this point
is because there's a number of cases
where you need to look at this same kind
of pattern you have a network definition
and then I have the forward light any
questions about that
yeah the earlier questions we haven't
called the forward layer
we've called a forward layer here so
that so we first create a network this
feed-forward constructor calls the init
this FF this is just a PI torch sort of
specific thing so you create an object
this object is callable in the PI torch
world and when you call it it first
passes through a bunch of stuff
internals in PI torch and then
eventually it ends up in that forward
call cool thank you
any other questions
optimizing scheduler service the
intruder
wrote a very thorough very good overview
I think it is here yes of gradient
descent optimization algorithms gradient
descent in general and then the
optimization algorithms for that this is
if you want to know exactly how they
work this is very useful to read but
this is a reasonably long post so I'm
not gonna go through this in detail the
idea in general so we have gradient
descent that just does an update to the
weights given a learning rate or like
weighted by a learning rate there's the
cast of gradient descent which then does
an update after every single example
after every single instance has been
passed through the network so in the
previous example we would do ten updates
with stochastic gradient descent and
there's many paths gradient descent
which is kind of the same thing but
instead of doing the update after every
single iteration or every single
instance you batch the instances in just
like this larger groups the idea is that
if you or when you batch the instances
into these larger groups it allows you
to when you're measuring your lost
function at the end the fact that you've
passed a little bit more data through
the network gives you a slightly better
understanding of what that what that
error gradient looks like you have a you
have a better sample given your data how
to do the parameter update and the size
of that mini batch is in some cases also
quite significant for the learning
itself but it's all it's dependent on
again if you're running this on a GPU
architecture you can only afford to do
mini batches that are small or large
enough to actually fit into the Jeep
you memory so if you have a GPU with 16
gigabytes of memory and your network
architecture already itself takes I
don't know 12 gigabytes well then you
can only do mini batches that fit into
that 4 gigabyte for 3 cos then you over
the idea also with stochastic gradient
descent that mini batch gradient descent
is that they do they use the same
parameter update the same learning rate
or all parameters in the network then
you have these adaptive learning rate
schedulers or optimizers rather
autograph arm is Pro Adam our Adam Adam
W the idea here is that well the not all
of the not all parameters in your data
set are equally frequent so you want to
adjust the updates that you do based on
how often you've seen certain kinds of
patterns so the adaptive learning rate
optimizers have some infill sort of
mechanisms that allow you to do that or
well they don't allow you to do they
sort of they do that for
[Music]
there's something I need to say about it
all right okay
so Adam used to be very popular I think
I don't exactly know where things are
heading at the moment but it seems to be
that this are Adam rectified Adam or an
atom W are reasonably popular at the
moment but that might change about three
weeks any questions about that okay
training the network so we load some
data there is a ah yes okay sorry this
is not actually loading this data so
this is just random Gaussian data from
there's a data generation function a
scalar and called mate walls what have I
done here to I think two gaussians 500
samples some number of features this we
set before and we have two centers we do
with training a test plate and we create
tensors out of those random sampler that
takes random samples out of these
tensors don't we have a trend we have a
data loader that sort of ideally moves
data back and forth and sort of dust
batching right we have a batch size of
eight now and then we have a learning
function I remember in the previous in
the example previously we just did a
forward pass we didn't do any parameter
objects and so we have a learning
function train model la some bookkeeping
for recording the losses you go through
some number of epochs you zero all the
gradients in the optimizer you set your
trading loss this is just bookkeeping
and then for all of the data points you
do a forward pass through your model
you measure whatever the loss was on
that model and that data inclusive
bookkeeping you back propagate the loss
this doesn't do any parameter updates by
the way this just updates what the the
information that is required to do the
parameter updates but the parameters are
still left untouched then you update the
problems and then if there's a scheduler
you update the scheduler and again you
zero out the gradients because this
gradients accumulate is this part
specific and then you do smoke so we
have a feed-forward and own a
feed-forward neural network we have a
loss function negative look like a loss
we have an optimizer we're just gonna
use SGD but we and we set the learning
rate to that there's a lambda scheduler
this doesn't actually do anything this
is mainly just there to illustrate how
you sort of create one this is just a
fixed learning rate of that model and
see what comes up
I forgot that I have to do that I got my
parents yeah I think I we are as I step
by step is there in default of need to
find a new partner that I tell this
should be eyes that pulled up
okay so you need to start the ISTEP from
one because otherwise you'll get a
division by zero error here or you can
do crosswalk there so that's a train
what all that seem to have run now and
now we are recording the losses from
various different from various different
what did I do
optimizers right so there's the classic
gradient descent and then there's Adam
so stochastic gradient descent for this
number of epochs and don't really see
I'm pretty sure this goes down a little
bit but you don't really see that for
stochastic gradient descent with
momentum plan and atom you see that the
loss on the I think this is on the
training data the loss on the training
data actually goes down reasonably
quickly so you're learning alright this
is the only point that I'm trying to
make here is that the optimizer actually
makes difference right we haven't done
anything naturalized yet we just have
random date and so let's do natural
language how do we turn natural language
into something that we complete into the
network so you owe who has heard of word
vectors I think everyone okay awesome so
we turn the natural language into word
vectors and for this we need to load the
word vectors this is just downloading
them you should all have downloaded the
word vectors already this is loading
them I'm gonna try to at least load the
small the small file which is not in the
downloads it's only on the USB stick so
if you don't have that you can load the
big one as well which is just gonna take
longer and take one network there's a
ton of stuff written about word practice
if you need to know more you want to
read more context on that there's a
bunch of links that's still running this
is kind of the general idea about word
vectors so you create some kind of a you
create an embedding you create a vector
for each word that captures some
distributional similarity some
contextual information on in which kinds
of contexts does that word appear in and
you want the vector to be some kind of a
representation of that this is just
taken from the
original words effect paper by McCall
you could do continuous bag of words
where the idea is to predict the word
given the context or the other way
around you predict the context given one
there's a whole bunch of other words
vectors I think what I do is yeah these
are the these are the fast text word
vectors okay and I'm sure you've all
seen this task so the idea is the word
vector class and Genting allows you to
do these similarity calculations or sort
of tasks but let me just blow the
English ones as well remember this is if
the vectors that you have there are
German vectors so the thing that is the
vector that is closest to Berlin is
Potsdam which is a town just outside of
Berlin Charlottenburg and my cone are
boroughs inside Berlin Hamburg you
probably all know one book is the state
where hot star is in and so on right so
whether or not these word vectors of
similarity tasks do exactly what you
expect them to do really depends on what
data they be trained on
I hope this loads quickly enough so that
I can show you I can show you this
similarity task on on the English and
the German word vectors and
[Music]
questions then someone have one question
while this is the hunt so what do you do
with word vectors and so the idea is
that you instead of doing what we did
here before where we just plant in
random vectors the idea is that you use
that word those word vectors as your
word representations so you create a you
created a dictionary essentially which
just Maps word indices global word
illnesses into their vector
representation and then that's fed into
that one there's an example here so
there's an example here feed-forward
network with embedding so what we do is
we have this exact same Slayer spec
that's coming in we have this exact same
layer definition that was in the
previous one but there's an additional
thing that is the embedding this again
this embedding layer comes from PI torch
and it is it is just a lookup takes
takes word indices and turns them into
vectors of vectors essentially where
those initial vectors are the are the
workers
okay that's gonna low that song and then
so that's the network definition and
then the forward functioning changes of
course as well because we need to pass
the X first rule the embedding layer
these turns so this X now contains this
X now contains integers that represent
word positions in some global dictionary
and that embedding layer turns those
integers into the vector representations
it just doesn't look up from the table
that it has you need to do a little bit
of sort of shifting of the results that
you get back but that's not relevant to
this so you get an embedding back and
then you feed the embedding to the layer
not originally you load some training
data
well spacey tokenizer model define eight
organization function what's important
here is this
so before we didn't have to worry about
the length of of any input data that we
have but of course natural language
doesn't come in sort of nice similarly
sized pieces of text every document
every sentence every utterance is has a
different length so we need to do
something about that now that thing has
loaded so I'm just gonna skip back
quickly and show you how this works
but I thought this was quite fun right
so in English
the most similar to Berlin are actually
other cities not girls inside Berlin and
then you could do that as well
hey I don't know why that happens in
German but that depends on training data
in English the most similar to Python -
okay right so this task you have
presumably all see there's a mystery so
you could is this convenient because you
can do arithmetic with this so we take
the vector for Berlin we take away
Germany and then we add France
I heard someone whisper Paris does
anyone have any other suggestions for
what's gonna come out of that everyone
everyone's happy with Paris
not exactly yeah and then you can do the
same thing with the English ones and you
get a slightly different song but again
these are not like you shouldn't think
of the word vectors as some kind of a
ground truth that if you have
pre-trained word embeddings they're just
gonna always correctly do the thing that
you want them to the whatever that
representation is is dependent on the
data that it was trained with and if you
use different word embeddings you might
get different results you likely will
get different results it depends a
little bit on what your task and so
finding out what exact embedding is the
correct one for your task requires you
to just test which one is the correct
one for your task but there's luckily an
abundance of word vector different kinds
of pre-trip vectors that you know okay
so where are we talking about
so we truncate our text run through all
right let me try to move all these
because this is gonna take a while
against right so with tokens we get some
message we run through each of the words
in the message we pass or pass the
message through the tokenizer run
through the text but alas and then we
turn this into word indices right so we
don't have tokens anymore we don't have
text now we have industries and
crucially we do this truncation so we
just say our documents are now a hundred
words and because we've said that the
documents are other words if the
documents are shorter we also need to
Pat them we just say that well anything
that goes beyond 80 words will just
replace all the rest with some special
pad
tope this word index is created here we
add one to these so we take everything
from the work vectors itself but we add
one to all of the indices because we
need that one extra space for the
padding zone and then we encode the
labels as well okay
hopefully that's not gonna take too long
to run do exactly the same thing with
the data Turnitin centers but now our
layer spec needs to change again so
before we had a layer spec that where
the input layer was 50 tokens now we
have 300 dimensional work vectors did I
remember - yes we have three hundred
dimensional word vectors so every single
word will create a vector of 300 of
length 300 but we also said that we're
gonna truncate our documents to 100 or
in this case 225 we need to account for
that in the bottom layer all right so
the bottom layer input is actually 300
by 25 and then you do the same thing
again and then the output is just power
many classes happens to be in our data
set this data set contains I think nine
classes read the layer spec and we get
oh I forgot to actually run this
this is gonna take quite a long time to
run I'll just stop it so this is also
not going to do anything particularly
useful the point is not to actually
create a useful predictor of this but
just show you how the word vectors are
actually fed into the network so let's
stop them that can go away and we have
some this actually said yeah so what is
this output this output where did that
come from
[Music]
doesn't matter maybe this is now I know
here Oh
output is the output from the
feed-forward neural network which is
right but this is whatever our batch
size was by the number of classes that
is in the dataset
make sense
now that seems like a rather simplistic
thing but it it work vectors like just
sort of simple concatenations of work
vectors tend to work for some document
classification tasks really well the the
fast text embeddings come from this
paper and they show some pretty good
results we run in production these
models like the fast text classifier
models and they're fine they're like
it's worth trying okay part two
currently all networks unless someone
has any questions well it's point of
word embeddings sort of like a picture
reduction step for future generations
that and then you're trying to reduce
your total number of total vocabulary
down to a smaller set of differences
right so so the question is is the point
of the word embeddings to somehow reduce
the dimensionality of the feature space
is what you're asking right okay no
that's not the point the point is that
the word embeddings capture so if you
look at this graph the point of the word
embeddings is to create is to create
representations of individual words that
have two properties one they are
arithmetic li-like they fit into the
world of linear algebra we can do
arithmetic operations with them we can
add them together we can subtract
subtract one from the other and so on
but the other important property is that
they contain some kind of a semantics or
some kind of a representation of the
semantics of the work
itself so as you saw here you can do
tasks like this you can take the vector
vector for Berlin and you can look at it
in the vector space and the entries that
are close to that vector for Berlin are
things that are similar to Berlin
this isn't a perfect system in sort of
this cases where that breaks down
because you have sort of so okay before
I go into that does that answer your
question I think so okay so with this
300 M dimensional vector space where the
rows are the part of 80 words okay
you couldn't just do a cluster analysis
on that right and ya find all the
staples all the countries should be
similar to Berlin yes you would hope
that all the capitals are similar to
each other but that's not always the
case that depends on the data that you
feed it but you could absolutely do
clustering that like there's all kinds
of neat applications or forward vectors
that that aren't as such related to
neural networks but you can do cluster
analysis you can do all kinds of
analysis of word usage over time how was
like how has the the meaning of
particular words how has that changed
over the centuries because because these
vectors allow you to capture somehow
that contextual information
similarity like in what sense it is
similar it like matter to me or is like
just right so in what in what way is it
similar this is the crucial point the
it's not similar semantically except the
in this in a strict sense the similarity
is measured in in a vector space
specifically as the cosine distance
between the two vectors right so it's a
geometric similarity measure but the
entire point is that that geometric
distance between the vectors is
representative of the semantic distance
in sort of in the human space does that
make sense right okay so I wanted to
come to this so there's there's
absolutely cases where this just breaks
down so you have things like you like
antenna opposites good and bad depending
on what exactly you want to do there
either of the opposites of each other or
they're actually very similar but if you
think of it in in the sense of like the
context in which good and bad are used
we can take like I don't know a good
Apple know about I will that's from that
that's not a good example this is a good
presentation and this is a bad
presentation but you can substitute one
word for the other without changing the
context but the word vector is captured
the context not like or they represent
the semantic meaning of the words
through the context but because you can
substitute those words good for bad it
means that often you end up having a
similar representation for good at that
I don't know if this is gonna work let's
see this
the English okay right does that make
sense because they like they are from it
for if you just think of sentences where
you would use these words you can
replace in that sentence often not
always but often good for bad and the
other way around
of course you change the semantic
meaning of the sentence but it's it's a
valid operation to do whereas I can't
record I can't replace good with
cauliflower right did that's that's kind
of the idea no approach is perfect no no
no but this is like this is it's a
really really good point like you
absolutely have to keep this in mind
when you're working with these that they
they're not they do not capture the sort
of our understanding of words or they
don't capture the same information about
words that we have they don't they're
very sort of they're very neat and
extremely useful but they're not a
universal thing I was just gonna point
out that if you use the German work it's
a nice example because if you use the
German word for good
select house pops up great so like
yes
so it's similarly they're making the
same analysis of the two different
courtesans yeah yeah this is later in
the end of this thing we're gonna get
into contextual word embeddings which
then changes this dynamic okay other
questions yes so recurrent neural
networks I think I need to go back to my
slides for this one recurrent neural
networks so this is a very simple
recurrent neural network so the idea is
in the previous example we had a fixed
length document that we either truncated
or pat it turn into vectors and fed that
into the into the architecture or of
course documents are not fixed length
they have vary in different language so
the idea is that you can capture that
you can capture these sort of sequential
models that or sequential data that may
or may not be infinite with recurrent
neural networks so you go through your
input one item at a time and the way
this is done is usually through some
kind of internal internal representation
conference internal representation that
or internal sort of state that the
network maintains throughout that data
processing and so what we have here this
is a simple recurrent neural network
called an element network here's our
input coming in and here's the hidden
state from the previous time step these
to the hidden state from the previous
time step and the input are integrated
together through a non-linearity
there's this orange box here contains
two sets of weights there's one set of
lights for the input
that's a trainable parameter there's
another set of weights for the hidden
state that's another trainable parameter
or set of parameters and then these
these two these two are sort of put
together to create the new next hidden
state that is then passed on to the next
iteration of that recurrent neural
network and then from that hidden state
you also produce the output through yet
another non linearity and there's yet a
third set of weights there this is not
what people actually do here's an LS TM
it's much more complex so you have the
hidden state the crucial idea here is
that in the ailment Network you just
have one hidden state in the LS TM you
have this hidden state but you also have
the cell state or like a contextual
information these contextual information
is this cell state is the thing that
gets updated you have three gates
there's a forget gate so from the
previous time step we take what the
context was what the cell state is and
we apply an update to it this is
essentially saying what is it given this
new input that is coming in what from
the previous time step do we need to
erase what what are what is information
that we can forget that gets passed
onwards and then there's an then there's
an update there's an addition here the
update is essentially sort of doing the
similar thing it computes two things
what needs to be updated which positions
in this internal cell state vector which
positions need to be updated and by how
much do they need to be updated
is it a plus 1 or minus 1 or plus 0.2
and so on these two are n again pulled
together yes so please yeah so these
sigmoid functions range between 0 and 1
so they cap either they either like
think of it you can think of it as a
binary thing whether you they completely
forget something or they completely keep
something this tan H is between minus 1
and 1 so it either sort of reduces the
activation of that position or it
increases the activation of that
position but that's why you have two
different functions to get those two
different ranges right and then you do
an update of the of the internal state
and again pass that on to the next time
yes yeah rectified linear units are used
although so this is the definition of
the LST M cell I think you can use a
rail like in between cells if you stack
them together or other sort of
activation non-linearity it's not super
important that you understand the exact
specifics of how this works the main
idea is to kind of one it's a group
relatively complex thing but it the fact
that you have this context that gets
sort of something gets forgotten from
the context and then other things get
added to the context they allow the LST
M cell to carry information over much
much longer distances in the sequence
then this simple
is that sort of roughly okay there's a
whole bunch of details on LSD ends this
lock positive if you really want to know
the exact details of how LSD ends work
I recommend that blog post by Chris Ola
it is very approachable but also very
detailed information and there's a whole
bunch of extensions and blah blah blah
one thing that I should say so the this
bit here specifically the there's this
there's a discussion perhaps I could say
going on in the NLP community that sort
of between the new kind of transformer
models which we're going to look at next
and these recurrent that because
language can be seen as a sequence
you must model language as a sequence
and it's not clear if that's actually
the case it has been the case before
that like these have greatly improved
performance at various different tasks
but it's it it's not clear if it's
actually necessary to model language or
text as one word following another word
there's some psychological evidence that
that's actually not how humans read and
there's also empirical evidence from
just neural network research that well
actually you get better results if you
don't do something else and this paper
is one starting point for looking into
that blah blah blah blah blah I've kind
of said all of this already
that's gentleman network
network in practice okay so this is
gonna take a little while to run again
let me just see where I can skip to so
the idea is that we're basically doing
it more or less the same thing as before
we load the German word vectors let me
just actually close these free up some
memory load the German word vectors we
turn the vectors into into indices we
have the embedding layer and then imply
torch you have an RNN implementation
which is the sort of days aren't an
implementation that's just an element
work and you can feed the vector Z there
you have some sentence you create where
the word indices out of that scent is
not defined because it is not called
that and here we go
there's a bunch of entries in the word
index table this is what you get out of
that operation that's re this operation
right so we're turning the words into
just individual index positions you run
that through the embedding layer but
notice that we now run the entire the
entire sentence in one go and you get
one output position her her sort of
entry in the center word in the sentence
alright this is the recurrence kind of
unwrapped
I'm sorry this is actually just the
embeddings right so this is now looking
up what the word embeddings are this is
whatever five six by 300 and then you
run this embedding through the RNN and
we get something that is one by six by
ten
I think I said somewhere that the
internal yeah here we go so the output
dimension of the RNN is 10 this is
exactly the kind of vector that you get
out of there
the hidden size is the same this is what
the output looks like that's what the
hidden size dead the hidden state in the
l1 network looks like are you okay with
this sort of this idea of just passing
in a bunch of data in the network
internally doing the recurrence okay
for what did I call it small
no I already loaded those tonight yes
but I called them something else so let
me change okay we add the unknown so
there's gonna be words in our data set
that are not in the pre trained word
embeddings so we add an unknown vector
which in this case we just set to a
random thing then we create a somewhat
strange training loop right so what's
happening here is we go through every
single document and we feed every single
document one by one into the recurrent
neural network I'm not actually going to
run that so it takes quite a long time
[Music]
but the idea is exactly the same that we
do we sort of take our data we feed it
through the network we measure the
lowest level you've all seen it before
well this is the crucial part here you
can do this but we don't need to do
anything to the neural network
architecture itself how its defined in
order for us to feed inputs that are of
varying different lengths it is
completely happy to just accept
documents that don't all have the same
like however this is very inefficient
because we we're having to iterate
through every single element every
single document in the data set one at a
time and we're using a GPU which are
going to need to for this kind of a
thing
you need to move every single document
one at a time into the memory of the GPU
and then back out again and then the
next one and then back out again
that slows down your training
matching the documents together is not
possible not because the network
wouldn't accept those but because the
internal sort of machinery of my torch
will just say you can't create a matrix
where the entries are of different
lengths so we have to do something about
that this is the only thing that's like
really pie chart specific however other
frameworks like tensorflow will have the
similar thing but it's not cold exactly
so the idea is that we do kind of we
compute the lengths of the documents and
we've had everything to the length of
the longest document or you can truncate
if you want and now our data set becomes
like this so these are now I think these
are like three thousand something long
vectors where for most documents most of
the entries are just zero and then we
can do that so you take in your in the
mini batches that you're taking you you
take the documents and the document
lengths which you're passing in here and
you pass that to the Poitras machinery
it'll create a matrix that is just big
enough to fit your documents and then
pass that matrix into the network what
you get back is exercise from the from
this output once you've passed it
through your lsdm cell is not the
original 3000 but it's whatever the
shortest document was in that batch this
can trip you up if you're not careful
okay then there's a whole bunch of stuff
that we can do now with LSD and so now
we have the machinery to run some
documents to an embedding layer through
LS TM and sort of patch everything
together and run the mini batches and so
on and then there's a bunch of stuff
that you can tweak where you can tweak
the parameters for the lsdm cells we can
change the hidden size representations
how wide are the layers in the LS here
or how wide sorry how wide is the that
context vector how much information
essentially are you allowing that
context vector vector to capture how
many layers is it a bi-directional STM
so why directional LS TM will
concatenate the representation of a
forward pass and a backward pass through
your over your data we add a classifier
so you have an LS TM sell that outputs
some kind of a representation and then
you have a linear layer that takes that
representation and output some number of
classes right we're still doing the same
document classification tasks that we
were doing in the previous thing so we
have nine classes but the LST M just
gives us if you want an embedding of the
document now we feed that embedding of
the document or documents into a linear
classifier layer that then outputs our
class problems and then we have some
optimize the parameters the optimizer
and so on
number of epochs and if we and again you
can see this is again this is more or
less exactly the same as all the
previous examples but here is one
crucial point so we run the data through
the LS TM now if you remember the LS TM
gave us a representation for each word
in the document the question is what do
you feed to the classifier so in this
case what we're doing is we're feeding
we let the illness TM run through each
document all the way to the end and we
take that last hidden state hoping that
that last hidden state captures the
semantics of the document that the LS TM
has just seen and that last state is fed
only that last day not the previous
states only that last state is fed into
the classifier layer what this bit here
is doing is exactly that it's just
indexing out of that lsdm output it
picks out for each document that is of a
different length it just picks out the
last state of each of those documents
then you pass that to the classifier and
then you do some bookkeeping and this is
where we get into a point where I can't
actually run this anymore
I can connect that it works
it smells too very good right so now the
question is well how does that
so I ran earlier some sort of benchmark
comparisons thank you some benchmark
comparisons on what happens when you
keep when you start fiddling with those
parameters the hidden size is it by
directional how many LS teams are
stacked together and here we have some
adult so the hidden size is 64 it's one
layer plus a linear classifier a hundred
epochs that's the optimizer that's the
amount of time it took to run on it on
an easy to p3 GPU it since and this is
what you get so overall f1 score or
accuracy is that here's we throw and
weighted f1 scores right if we just
focus on the accuracy eighty percent
then we do what is different optimizer
same amount of time spent we get a
little bit better performance these
changes obviously if you changed how how
long you run the lsdm or the dot track
we can increase the size of that inner
representation we've now doubled the
representation all the information
content of the LS TM of that internal
representation we've added a second
layer so now you're not passing that
initial output that you get from the LS
TM that consumes the input is not going
to the classifier it's going to another
lsdm so you have two of them on top of
each other and of working together
and again you get slightly better
performance but you've also doubled your
trade and then you can do all right okay
so here's an interesting question what's
better deeper networks or wider networks
or or deeper in one depends the
community is sort of verging on deeper
but it's not clear to me exactly why
there seems to be some evidence
suggesting that
it's better to have deeper networks than
it is to have wider yeah so obviously
you if you have the time and the money
is like the last one took 17 minutes of
it over an hour you can keep going and
like spend a couple weeks running these
experiments and then you'll have your
answer but but yeah so here you can see
so the 2 layer 128 with LST n we get 85%
accuracy a four layer LST M with
slightly smaller internal
representations that we get slightly
worse not exactly right questions let me
see book is this actually right yeah
this training is working but I'm just
gonna stop this because I don't think
we're gonna see any output from that
during this presentation questions how I
lost everyone is that why you don't have
questions or I'm just going through this
so thoroughly that I feel really clear
goldfish yes I just was wondering you
might clarify the linear classifier and
what that layer is so the linear
classifier just takes that last output
from the LS TM and has a a linear layer
which so hold on what is it a fully
connected layer which takes so the LST M
hold on the LST M size here is 64 but we
have nine classes so that fully
connected layer just translates this 64
tonight okay that's right I thought so
linear is sort of a synonym for like
fully collinear yet fully connected but
also there is no non-linearity in there
but so if you think back to what the
lsdm has there's a whole bunch of
different activation functions and blood
of life the linear layer is just you've
multiplied a set of weights with some
inputs that's just a linear function
other questions
how bad does it get when you don't get
my direction
[Music]
that's not my direction oh is a tattoo
here this is but like this is six two
four and one layer and then the
bi-directional is 128 and two layer yes
I didn't do proper kind of analysis but
the other one above it is bi-directional
one layer I know these are two these are
both one layer but you have a different
you have a different optimizer teach the
GPU instances on Addison be like the
hourly price looks a little scary but
it's not I mean this altogether took
less than half a day so that's like I
don't know 10 bucks so it's not like if
I recommend that you go and try it's not
that expensive it gets expensive when
you start running the really big GPU
machines for a couple of weeks to train
like really big networks sure that gets
expensive but just sort of playing
around with this a little bit
you're fine I actually tried and so
sorry so Google collab has GPU instances
that you can use for free you can take
these notebooks and just upload them to
Google Cola and they have GPU instances
but it wasn't like they worked okay it
wasn't particularly fast it's faster
than running it on your laptop you can
always cut down the size of the data set
for instance if you just want to play
around with them that's to come as a no
no offering financial cost it'll just
cost you time
right so then I'm gonna sort of skip
through a couple of ideas I'm starting
to run out of time but I'm gonna skip
through a couple of ideas there's no
code here this is just sort of giving
you a some kind of an overview where
where we're headed with what you what I
think it would be useful for you to be
aware so sequence to sequence learning
and encoder/decoder
architecture and so sequence the
sequence learning the idea is that you
have this comes from sort of the machine
learning machine translation air era era
area so you have a sequence in German
and you want to translate that into a
sequence in Finnish those two sequences
don't necessarily have the same length
so the idea is similar to what we did
before where you have an LS TM or two
stacked on top of each other or four
stacked on top of each other that
creates some kind of some kind of a
representation of what the content is
that was just consumed you have a
different thing that linear classifier
that which would on top that then
consumes that out that embedding that
representation the encoder decoder
architecture the idea is the same but
instead of having a classifier a linear
layer on top you have another recurrent
neural network that consumes that final
hidden State so you have one RN n1l STM
that produces a some kind of an
embedding of the input of all of the
input you have a second one the decoder
that forgiving that embedded state
decodes and produces a different
language or I don't know some other
output the problem that the somewhat
obvious problem here is that that you're
putting an immense burden on that hidden
representation to capture accurately
what the input was this is where the
whole attention business comes in you
can use attention
- so the attention sort of gives the
decoder Network has a way to compute how
important was how important were the
words in the input sequence for the
output that the decoder needs to be use
so it gives the decoder a kind of a
weighted representation of of the heat
input is actually there's a bunch of
stuff here that I looked up where you
can go like this article
hat is a really really long detailed
article about different kinds of ways of
applying attention that's the original
paper this illustrated attention is
maybe a good place to start because it
you know in a very kind of nice
pictorial form goes over what that what
the idea behind the tensions I always
find pictures to be extremely helpful
there's also a PI coach tutorial in the
documentation itself specifically on
machine translation with attention so
you can go and download the notebook and
then just look at it for yourself run
through it
right so now we get to contextual
embeddings and transfer learning okay we
did you have a question okay contextual
embedding so the idea is that oh this is
not charging my laptop I'm gonna run out
of batteries or panic panic panic okay
why is this not on I need I need some
way of charging
Oh
okay that's very maybe my laptop is
problem ah okay good good so um
contextual weird openings so the the
idea behind contextual where they're
betting's is that the these word
representations these word vectors that
we had before they were static you just
had some corpus some data you learned
them and then that's it but the meaning
of words
changes depending on the context in a
dynamic way as an example so as I said I
I live in Berlin where's my house I live
in Berlin I actually do live in Berlin
and I actually do usually cycle to work
but I also work for travel tech company
so what we're interested in finding is
we want to find the or for instance the
origins and the destinations of flights
that people want to book with us so we
need to be able to identify whether some
mention of a location is the origin of a
flight now clearly I live in Berlin and
usually cycle to work and Connie book me
a flight from Berlin to New York in both
cases Berlin is a location but only in
the other case is it a destination sorry
the origin of the [ __ ]
so that meaning of the word in this
specific context is dependent on the on
the words that are around this brings us
to contextual word embeddings so now the
idea is that you don't just create a
fixed lookup table for the word
embeddings but you actually have some
machinery that is part of the network
itself that you are that you're running
and that integrated machinery as you are
as you are learning but also at
prediction time it
actively computes it creates these word
embeddings that's just part of the part
of what if what it does does that make
sense there's a bunch of different ways
of doing that you've already seen one
the LS TM that we had before the output
from the LS TM can I find it ah right
you have one
he didn't state her work you could if
you wanted to say that that hidden state
at that position for that word is a
contextual embedding of that word given
what surrounded and this is exactly the
idea that people have them taken and
sort of carrot for again here's a bunch
of research papers introducing that this
paper kind of introduced in a very
significant way the idea of transfer
learning general networks
so from these contextual embedding we
get to relax use models and training
sort of deep networks that have
integrated not just the ability to
create contextual beddings
but have actually hopefully learned
something on language in general and
then we take that entire network
architecture and we transfer it to a
different task usually these are trained
to be language models first so the idea
is to just be able to predict what the
next word in the sequence is but that
task allows the network to capture some
kind of
of inherent properties of language
itself which are then useful for
whatever your final task is in our case
document classification and again the
idea is exactly the same whatever that
language model large network
architecture is you take that and you
put a tiny little linear layer on top as
your classifier if that's the task that
you're doing is a little playground area
here or playing around with a pre
trained language model you can actually
like use it to generate language as well
but I have 15 minutes of time left so
we're not missing the mighty transformer
okay so the idea here is I gave a wet
jokes already so these word embeddings
right they're very useful because they
allow you to compose together word
meaning so you can take the
representation of red and you can take
the representation of car now you want
to know what the joke is you get a red
car you put them together and you get a
red car maybe you add that maybe you
multiply it who knows that's not the
only way of creating word
representations the you can also create
references they wrote the word
representations that capture various
different sort of grammatical
relationships between words so we have a
lovely group here and there's a lovely
is an adjective or modifier of group we
can use this information to create a
representation that specifically targets
this kind of information this is a bunch
of research that was done at the
research group where did my PhD this is
not my research it was done by my
colleagues so the idea is that you go
through a bunch of data and you extract
these adjectives or modifier and like
all of these dependency structures you
create a bit graphic that and you can
now say that well music is anything that
is related to it
so music can be lovely or blue or loud
but the representation for music is the
network structure within which it exists
the point that I want to get across here
is that word embeddings is not the only
way of doing this it just happens to be
very convenient support linear algebra
because these network structures are
very difficult to add together and
subtract from each other there's also
the kind of this the what I said earlier
about the language models and not
language models but these recurrent
neural networks and language being a
sequential structure and you having to
sort of represent or model language as a
sequential structure the is this NLP is
clever Hans moment kind of it gets to
the point that that transformer
architectures that I'm going to talk
about next they sort of they learn
things about language that we're not
entirely sure what those things are and
it's not clear if those things are
representative of of like linguistic
structure in general and it's just
learning some sort of patterns that
happen to be useful given the data set
that you have but I work as an NLP
engineer I don't particularly care if
the network correctly represents
linguistics and if it depends on what
you're applying those methods to but
it's completely okay to use
methodologies that are not necessarily
accurate linguistically as long as they
actually improve performance at the task
that you're trying to achieve why why do
you care if it represents language
correctly
it improves performance period right
burn and the transform this is the
transformer architecture we're just
gonna ignore the other part so this is a
beastie beast there's two parts to it
one is the encoder you've already seen
an encoder in the LSC M the other one is
the decoder but Bert which I will
actually talk about doesn't use the
decoder it just stacks these encoder
bits on top of each other and I'm gonna
talk specifically about two parts one is
the input headings how you feed data
into it the second is that multi
retention so the idea behind this
transformer is that instead of consuming
data sequentially which is
computationally inefficient you have to
consume one thing after the other that
puts a constraint on how fast you can
actually process data transformer just
slurps in the entire sequence in one go
but now it's not clear anymore how do
you represent that contextual
information that you before in the
recurrent neural network architecture
we're capturing in that context state
that was updated after each recurrent
step okay but first the input embedding
so the Transformers and a lot of other
neural network methods nowadays as well
they use something called a byte pair
encoding or sub word tokenization
so they will split they will split words
into sort of just some sequences of
characters that may or may not be
complete words that we as humans would
recognize why would you do this
so I am a native finished speaker and
here's a couple of examples of how
finished works we don't have
prepositions any Finnish creates meaning
in words by just sort of adding stuff to
them so here's a word Allah to drive is
the imperative form of that word drive
here's a driver here's someone who makes
the driver drive for instance the
passenger in the taxi
here's the boss of the taxi company
making the taxi driver drive
it's a weird language but it's also a
wonderful language I recommend that you
all learn it there any finished native
Finnish speakers anyone no right you can
also do each day you can say sort of if
I should casually drive and now because
you're all hyper intelligent people I'm
sure you can all tell me what this would
be no one I thought sorry yes it is then
what the last bit is con well I know it
is yeah okay but I hope these sort of
motivates well I admit that yes Finnish
is an esoteric language but Finnish
isn't the only language that does this
there's similar effects in German it's
actually similar effects in English as
well you have described and prescribed
right those are prefixes that change the
meaning of scribe you don't usually
think of them as prefixes but they are
prefixes okay right so that's quite
current coding it doesn't work like the
system doesn't split things into neat
kind of prefixes like pre and D and so
on
it's a data-driven approach to
tokenization and the bird model comes
with its own tokens so now the question
is right how do we do the contextual and
gold encoding so this transformer
architecture or this like beep that you
saw before these encoders they are the
things that do that contextual encode
how do they do that well this is roughly
how they do that so we're interested
again in the reference
of Berlin now we want the representation
of Berlin to include the context that we
have here so what the encoders do is
they they allow each of these words or
to be accurate the word vector of the
sub words of each of those words to have
an influence on the final representation
of this target work so there's a bunch
of sort of weightings that are computed
in those encoder blocks that then
finally create this representation right
notice that these numbers are different
to these numbers that's this is
meaningful
it is purposeful because then the
encoder then sits here in between has
taken the representation of all of this
and sort of folded it in to the
representation of the target word the
way this is learned is they actually do
a masked language model tasks where
during the initial training phase the
network needs to be able to predict from
that context what that middle word is
that some words are randomly masked out
from the sentences and those masked
words those deleted words from the
sentences need to be in the output of
the poster network for that particular
iteration notice that this is very
similar conceptually to the skip grammar
no from the continuous package bag of
words where from the context the tag is
to predict other task is to predict what
the words let's do
okay so five minutes left
we're not gonna do any code original
paper is a bunch of really really good
very detailed very approachable articles
on the transformer model there's a lot
of work right now being done on model
compression because these are ginormous
things so it would be useful if we can
run them on an architect or compute
Hardware isn't quite as expansive
there's also a bunch of problems with
interpretability the claim is to some
extent that these attention weights that
the network is learning can be used to
interpret how the network is actually
doing its prediction but then there's
also some research saying that software
tokenization and hold up let me just see
if there's something that you really
need to know here I mean you can take
all of this and just run it later on
your own maybe this can I run this on
its own
he to load everything okay the idea here
was to show what the lots of different
learning rate schedules - so I talk
right up the beginnings that at first
you have to or you want to have a really
really low small learning rate so that
the updates when the network hasn't seen
a lot of data the updates that you're
doing are very small and then they
gradually increase this is just voting
that document classification again the
idea is exactly the same as you have as
we see also already previously you have
this giant network architecture and then
a tiny little document classifier a
linear layer that sits on top and you
let the network do the encoding of the
text and then you just use that in your
final prediction task there's a couple
of different ways you can do that in the
this two examples here you can either
adjust the weights of just that final
classifier layer which turns out not to
produce particularly good results
right before we had accuracy around 84
85 but you could also just open up the
entire transform and stack the complete
network architecture and just optimize
everything and then you get much better
performance no this is wrong it should
be 85 not 55 okay I need to correct that
and then this is finally a linear SVM
that runs on a laptop it works great
answer
so the nearest you better yeah this is
not so for document classification I'm
not sure if these like large transformer
architectures is what you want to go
with but we use this in production where
we do word level prediction well
basically what I showed you before that
like is Berlin the origin or a
destination or neither we use it for
that whole thing and this is way better
than that
I tried thus far anything else okay I
think that's it and I'm also hard time
questions that's a bad side okay
one thing I forgot because these
networks are so large they also consume
a lot of energy so there's another
another bunch of research that's going
to be done is on creating first of all
measuring the energy efficiency and then
also creating models that are
computationally not quite as expensive
there's a workshop proposal for the 2020
MLP on kind of sustainable NOP so these
models you need a GPU for but the field
as a whole is sort of coming to the
realization that we are not in college
or if that's necessary let's try to fine
tune slightly less computationally
expensive things do these things with
finally I want to thank a bunch of my
colleagues who helped in creating this
I'm gonna David Mark and Tobias they
were extremely helpful in providing
feedback for this and I want to thank my
employer for actually allowing me to
come thank you all
[Applause]